hey college boy why don't you make like  you did it you a see and leave before  you get started good ones so thanks  bangles coach it's Zack Taylor Oscar  Isaac Daisy Ridley Airy the clip  DeLorean is it true you had a losing  record in college yeah you're hired  here's the get pass gonna meet you he's  so small okay we have to go now let's go  rule the Eagles for you next bounty we  want close losses to good teams that  will destroy that child hey how do you  like yours do cool things  who wants a baby I'm Dan Schneider and  I'm abandoning babies now  it's me Zach Taylor coach of the  Cincinnati Bengals in gridiron Heights  as hot new breakout character please  subscribe below so every episode can  have more Zach Taylor we're gonna have  Zach Taylor t-shirt Zach Taylor plushies  like Taylor video games Zach attack  y'all